[Musique]
tu vas être en retard j'arrive j'arrive
au nom tient merci mon nom un pays ne
vaut que par la qualité de ses
dirigeants laissez les tranquilles un
vrai roi et bravent les nobles joue pas
les héros je suis roi ici tu as encore
d'autres combats à mener
à présent tu dois choisir ce pour quoi
tu te barres medders regarde ce que j'ai
trouvé quelque chose est écrit sur la
garde va voir sur google traduction
ça veut dire l'épée d'arthur et si tu
étais la seule personne qui pouvait
retirer cet ep et si c'était excalibur
[Musique]
enfin suivez moi je suis merlin je
croyais que berlin était un vieil âge un
ingénieux déguisement est ce pas
dans quatre jours la sorcière morgan
s'emparera du monde arrivé qu'une fois
ma carrière je suis censé la stopper
c'est n'importe quoi voilà ton épée et
je te souhaite bonne chance pour la
suite
tu mets un roi alexander les bêtas
choisi pourquoi on t'aiderai vous êtes
les gens les plus forts que je connaisse
vous êtes mes chevalier et c'est la
table ronde vite bidders relève les
rabats toi alors tu es trop un geek
c'est le destin
c'est comme dans toutes les histoires
qu'on a lu luke skywalker harry potter
un truc incroyable arrivent ils
découvrent qu'ils descendent d'une
famille aux pouvoirs magiques
maman ne fuit pas d'accord
et ce soir
c'est la meilleure et la pire chose qui
me soit jamais arrivée
saluons le roi pour l'éternité
non s'il vous plaît ça me gêne
wisques d'après un conte du et mario
kart
c'est soit un type cas dans la danse
depuis qu'il est tout petit
son truc à lui c'est le hip hop sa mère
elle c'était la danse classique
pour lui c'est une artiste raté il a
terriblement père damir sanguine
sauf qu'ils se trompent je vois ce que
tu sais faire
je m'installe sur paris tu t'es là pour
longtemps juste le temps de passer le
concours
sylla faut vraiment qu'ils trouvent un
boulot jabil j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter vos nouveaux professeurs on
n'a pas de comptes à bord entre c'est à
nous de décider qui donne quoi tout est
dans le style
il n'y a pas de règle parce que le hip
hop ça vient des tripes
j'en parle j'ai quitté son sujet ce
guide et je leur ai montré ça marche pas
civile comme prof c'est toi confiance
est ce que ça vous tenterait de
participer à un concours de hip hop
nixon hostile
un hip hop airs classiques
on va finir par radio
radio avec comme elle m'a beaucoup parlé
du elle ne m'a pas dit que vous étiez
6004 nous c'est le concours pour entrer
à l'école de l'opéra
jean m j'aurais tort bien quand avait 8
ans tu as de quoi là maintenant ce que
tu te rends compte qu'on peut pas gagner
le concours sur toi tu veux pas on n'a
pas fait tout ça pour rien burqa elle
pas du genre à donner
le doute a toujours été mon pire ennemi
la peur de pas être à la hauteur
je te vois danser quand je danse avec
toi je vibre
même si t'es pas là
je pense avec toi
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais ressenti autant de fierté
ou de satisfaction qu'en accomplissant
une mission avec vous tout ce qu'on a
fait est que je vois quand on en est
réduit aujourd'hui essayer de faire
bouger les choses dans ce pays on n'a
jamais piqué un centime
tu t'es fait tirer dessus 5 fois pour
ton pays et tu as même pas de quoi
envoyer ses gamines à la fac j'ai un job
pour toi je suis passé à autre chose
fish j'ai besoin d'un pilote et il ya le
bébé maintenant ça pourrait changer ta
vie et celle de ton monde pour de bon
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser nos
compétences pour notre propre profit ça
marche on fait
[Musique]
je veux faire tomber gabriel martin
lauréat c'est le chef des plus gros
cartels
d'après mes estimations il ya plus de 75
millions de dollars mais si on disparaît
pas dans la nature juste après on n'a
aucune chance
après ce soir vous ne pourrez pas
reprendre une vie normale
soyez conscient on s'apprête à devenir
des criminels
tout le monde dans le bureau tout de
suite c'est un truc de malade
shi les gardent bien viennent vous
consentirez on prend chacun un sac à dos
plein ça va le faire
non il ya 100 millions de dollars qui
les attendent dans le van n'est pas
question de leur laisser le moindre
billet à autre chose à proposer
on va devoir être rapide c'est pas pour
ça que j'avais signé au départ on arrête
tout la [ __ ] on s'active abonnez-vous
tu as vu le bordel qu on a foutu ça se
fait pas on laisse pas un merdier pareil
il a pas que l'argent de l'oréal il ya
plein d'autres gens qui vont en avoir
après vous il nous a menti ce sera
pareil dans toutes les lignes
ya pas 36 solutions
[Musique]
toujours un peu plus compliqué que prévu
au final
un peu plus faire marche arrière
je suis sûr à tous et leur culture
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un s'il tenait dans la
région de chambre à air dérailleur c'est
bien moi raul tabur à la réputation est
telle qu'on ne dit plus un vélo mais un
culte à murat
et pourtant
je n'ai jamais su monter à mios et mon
âme c'est que jamais personne ne m'a cru
ne bougez pas je m'appelais enrichi
gougne notre complicité fut timide je ne
savais pas faire de nous étions comme
deux vieux amis d'enfance figoni avait
réalisé quelques portraits notable pour
son projet un village des visages on ne
disait plus une photo mais une figue uni
on a refait un tout petit peu plus
fatigué avec de l'éveil il manque un
truc là non toi sur ton beau vélo
descendant les peuples indiqué se fait
tellement longtemps que lui livre qu'est
ce qui t'empêche de faire cette fille
connue
[Musique]
du säntis city sur les photos ça fait un
moment que nous ne voulait pas pu la
faire ta faute d'accord il ya des
instants comme cela dans la vie
[Musique]
on sait qu'il y aura un avant
et un après a ajouté
[Musique]
tous vont enfin comprendre comment ma
vie entière paraît s'est bâtie sur un
mensonge
et si c'était aujourd'hui le déclic
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
pourquoi je peux payer les instants mais
moi j'ai tout compris l'isi te dis que
le privé tu vas pas aimé c'est c'est
tout propre c'est honnête a rien qui
dépasse les revient mais non qu'est ce
que tu fous que la dame a les enfants
les dames de la cantine voudrais savoir
qui est en situation d'arabité
pigmentaire approbation musulmane qui
mange du cochon il était malade
certains lots en fait on a enlevé de
l'école pour le mettre à saint-benoît on
veut ce qu'il ya de mieux pour nos
gosses pas c'est normal
écoute florentin c'est le sel de la
classe sl quoi jeune blanc tu me dis ça
- en plus rythmé la mixité faut que ce
soit de l'exciter pour ce soit de la
mixité si ça n'est pas la mixité ça
n'est pas de la mixité tu vois voici
saint-benoît notre protecteur mais
l'école est aussi accessible aux non
croyants
alors moi je suis avocate et lui et
musiciens professionnels
je vois que vous avez fait un clip
[Musique]
m
c'est comme s'il y a plus d'école pour
les gens comme nous je ne suis pas
refaire ça me fout de la gueule de tout
de même je crois en rien encore tout
fait fort avec des principes de mes nos
enfants ils ont vachement besoin de nous
ils vous reprochent pas vos absences
commentant
[Musique]
bonjour madame jacques gamins qui ne va
pas bien là vous comprenez pas je suis
père de merde en ce moment
il est bien il avec ses copains j'ai des
gens comme vous semblez quand on est
foutu là
c'est à dire personne ne leur culot
censure acculé le pape
et surtout il est surtout à la batterie
voilà puis les paroles aussi le principe
des paroles combien tu as deux balles
dans la couenne toi c'est quoi ce serait
bien tu vois un médecin un de ses cadres
ne serait bien toi tu vois un médecin un
de ces quatre j'ai pas des balles dans
le corps moi mais ça c'est parce que
j'étais toujours couverts
t'es au courant pour l'évasion s'était
bonnie & clyde madame le gouverneur il
faut que ça cesse ils ont commis de
nombreux vols à main armée et des
meurtres de sang froid
un commentaire sur l'évasion nous allons
capturer bonnie & clyde écrivait cette
phrase est soulignée la 2 fois je ne
connais qu'un homme capable de les
arrêter
je vais revenir il ya de la place pour
moi t'es même pas équipés
allez monte on est en 1934 ce sont des
gangsters avec des mitraillettes et vous
voulez connais comme altrad bonnie &
clyde des texas rangers spécial la
police dans le missouri et vient de
signaler une terrible fusillade entre
les gangsters bonnie & clyde et des
représentants de l'ordre
give me feu c'est une opération très
organisés barrage surveillance aérienne
maintenant vous êtes à la retraite
cowboys en quoi est en train de se
transformer ce monde à une époque il
fallait du talent pour être publiés
alors que maintenant suffit de tuer des
gens
et la retourner vers elle avec son pied
pour qu'ils comprennent bien ce qui
laisse passer salut chérie c'est allé
trop loin
on va les descendre c'est une excellente
idée
[Musique]
qui êtes vous j'imagine qu'on est les
méchants
et ça
t'as pas choisi le bon endroit par ici
klein c'est un roi
clyde et est un roi mais moi je suis un
texas ranger trou du cul